lo primero es también un poco de
contexto porque yo estuve hace un año en
la conferencia de seguridad de múnich
donde el tema de la pandemia ya era uno
de los grandes temas de discusión
también ya se hablaba en ese momento de
no solamente los retos a nivel global
sino también de la necesidad de
solidaridad internacional en el tema de
la pandemia ya era uno de los temas
grandes de discusión en su momento
aunque por supuesto todavía no se sabían
las dimensiones que iba a tomar la
pandemia en los próximos meses pero eso
para explicar un poco porque la actual
intervención que estábamos escuchando
también resulta tan importante porque en
últimas se trata de todos esos desafíos
que continúan que se continúan también
en el tema económico no es solamente la
continuación de el tema de materia de
salud sino también de los retos y
desafíos económicos en particular para
alemania y para la unión europea se
trata de un desafío de enormes
proporciones alemania ya inyectó
muchísimo dinero aquí para tratar de
mínimis
y los riesgos económicos a lo que por
supuesto también han hecho otros países
y es algo que por supuesto continúa como
uno de los desafíos en los próximos años
porque aunque continúen las vacunas
aunque se reduzcan los números de
contagiados aunque se reduzcan los
números de muertes no solamente aquí en
alemania sino también a nivel
internacional lo que va a permanecer
también son esos legados de la pandemia
en materia de economía en materia de
desarrollo también y de ahí que para
alemania y para la unión europea en
general sea este quizás uno de los
desafíos más importantes en los próximos
años también más allá de quién esté en
el gobierno alemán una vez angela merkel
de la cancillería perdida en septiembre
así es tomás gracias por esa información
y por el contexto que nos ha dado en
este momento